know yourself Follow Your Passion make
your work and passion the same thing
while considering the money part because
money will get you freedom and choice
and be able to make that but if you know
yourself feel the pull and pursue that
passion understand on your journey your
hero's journey that you will have
mistakes and you will have weaknesses
and to understand those not fight those
because by understanding mistakes you
will learn not to make mistakes again I
have a principle which is pain plus
reflection equals progress so that
reflection is important to know yourself
know your pulls know your weaknesses and
when you also know your weaknesses and
the strengths of other people there are
people who have strengths where you're
weak and you have strengths where
they're weak and to be able to work well
together is the most effective way of
achieving success Nina motivation watch
the top 10 with hashtag believe Nation
hey it's Evan Carl Michael and I make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best Ray dalio and
my take on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy
rule number two learn from failures then
you start your own company right yeah
and when incredibly well at the
beginning
1975. it was me a guy played rugby with
in my two bedroom apartment okay and uh
everything went well until it didn't go
well that's right and did you then have
to go borrow money from your father yeah
so yes so what happened was you know
um it was a very small company just uh
you know a handful of people and I love
to trade the markets and we did it for
institutions and then he
um and then in
1979 80 81 I calculated that uh foreign
that the American Banks had lent more
money to foreign countries than the
countries are going to get paid back
and um and I had its controversial world
view that the world you know is going to
be the big debt crisis and Mexico
defaulted in 1982 so very interesting
1982.
and um when they defaulted I got a lot
of attention and I thought we were going
to have a terrible economic set of
circumstances and I could not have been
more wrong
it was exactly the opposite in August
when they defaulted another country
started to default it was the exact
bottom in the stock market and so I had
to let off everybody and I was down to
me and I
um you know I said to myself well am I
going to have to put on a tie and go
drop take the train in and go to Wall
Street and so on I couldn't bring myself
to do that
um and I I was so broke that I had to
borrow four thousand dollars for my dad
to pay the bills and this was the best
thing that ever happened to me I mean
painful but it was one of the best
things that ever happened to me because
um it gave me the humility I needed to
balance with my audacity and then I I
needed to understand how can I have the
upside without having the downside you
know how and then I understood the
portfolio construction and risk
management and so on so forth so that
was my bottom and that punch in the face
that experience was one of the best
things that happened did you pay your
father back it's a some point the four
thousand dollars plus he didn't want
equity in Bridgewater
he didn't ask me no I think he he was
smarter than that rule number three
build Equanimity I think the key is to
think of reality as
you're given reality is reality and
think of it as working like a machine
they're a cause effect relationships
that make the realities around you okay
now if you go above yourself and you
look at that how does that machine work
and then how do I interact with that
machine to get what I want and you do
that with an Equanimity meditation also
helped me a lot yes I learned to
meditate uh very in many years ago
um and uh if you could if you have
Equanimity and you look at it above and
you look at with curiosity and you say
oh I must not be interacting well with
at my reality and how do I change it and
how does it work it's a very powerful
way of approaching life rule number four
learn how to take notes if I'm making a
decision
um that that after I make the decision
usually or right at the time if I pause
and reflect and I write my principle
down in other words principle is sort of
a recipe what would I use to how would I
make that decision and what are the
criteria around it I find that I make it
much more clear it becomes clearer and
it applies to the next thing that comes
along it'll be that way because
everything happens over and over and
over again and I think people make the
mistake of looking at just the one like
it's the first one they have I don't
know they have the first problem of this
sort of the first child or whatever it
is and this has been happening plenty of
times and so if you have the principles
I found that that helped me think more
clearly about it and it helped me
communicate better like why and so over
the years over the last 30 years or so
that's what I I've done I did it
originally to communicate very well with
people I work with you know I set up my
company and and it was very important to
have good communication and then we
could debate the principles and so
that's the process I urge people to do
that there are many excellent decision
makers
um and I just wish that they wrote down
their principles when this set so for
example we'll be talking about Henry
Kissinger and his new book is going to
come out with a book on leadership
and don't just describe the leaders
describe then what about them were the
Essential Elements to make a good leader
under what circumstances and so if we
think about that when then also then you
begin to think in a principled way and
then when you start to think in a
principal way life becomes it's so much
easier to make decisions and it's so
much less confusing because it's like
coming up on a species and you say okay
well what species is it not just another
it's a thing no what species is it and
how do I deal with that species
effectively and and so that's what that
is and so I encourage people to write it
down I wish anybody who's successful
wrote down their principles or their
recipes for making those types of
decisions
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five practice
meditation in 1968 The Beatles went to
India and they meditated and then I
heard about it and then in 1969 in New
York you could
um you can bring some flowers and you
could be that and you could learn how to
meditate and and why wow I recommend
it's the best thing gift I can do it
every day or every almost ever almost
yeah I try to do it every day I try to
do it about twice a day and if I could
take a second to describe it
um what it is
um is it frees your mind of thought and
it takes you from a conscious State into
your subconscious and your subconscious
is where creativity comes from and
Equanimity and and all of that like if
you're calm and great ideas come to you
and when you have that Equanimity then
you as you're approaching everything
things are just the way they are and you
have to deal with them and it's a little
like being you know in the ninja movies
it's a little bit like being the ninja
and everything seems slower and you can
handle it better and so and you align
your subconscious which is where the
motions and also Inspirations come from
with your conscious mind and when
they're aligned and you have that
Equanimity it's a great thing rule
number six know your nature I think
first of all one has to know their
nature
um
you might have to discover it but your
nature means do you have a sense of
adventure do you seek security are you
an extrovert and introvert those types
of things so personal Discovery is
important
I think that who you're with
and where you are is more important than
what you do because in the early phase
of that second phase it's total
Discovery so it's experimentation you
know you went to India for three years
right yes and and that but if you have
that sense of adventure to let go you
can discover that's your opportunity but
discover yourself as well as to discover
what the choices are like and then as
you move later into that you'll feel the
pulls
um and to feel never trapped we were
talking just before we began that so
many people say
um you know I can't be that way because
I my job won't allow it which is a silly
concept because you have the freedom of
those choices even in when you have
constraining uh situations
so I think uh that's the life Arc
enjoy this wide open choice you can be
anywhere in the world you can do almost
anything let go experiment and then move
on rule number seven share knowledge to
others to give the knowledge uh teach a
man how to fish is better than to give
him a fish I mean I think you can give
them both you can give education and you
can sure but uh ability the the capacity
to be productive because you know if I
can give you the capacity to go out in
the world it's like go into a jungle I
give you a knife and can you live in the
jungle okay if I give you that capacity
that's the best thing I can give you
that's why I wrote the book and you know
pass it on I wrote those principles over
years and I wrote them down and that's
what I want to pass along that's the
most important thing yeah but but if you
but if you've got money you can help
people a lot in a lot of different ways
with which is thrilling what would you
say then are the three greatest skills
that people that aren't financially
abundant or that are struggling
financially should learn to master in
order to be in a better position
financially three skills what would you
say they should learn well as I said
before I remember watching the movie I
was young David Copperfield with WC
Fields and he speaks to David
Copperfield and he says he said
something like and I'll put it in dollar
terms you're at a hundred dollars and
you spend 105 dollars
that's misery
if you earn a hundred dollars and you
spend ninety five dollars you'll have a
good life
I mean what wasn't exactly like that but
it was but but basically
I know so many people who don't earn
much but are there because if you start
to think about what it is that it costs
you to live in terms of let's say the
basics you know uh give me a bit to
sleep and give me the food let me be
educated and so on so forth I think most
people can get themselves in a position
where you know they're not positive so
if you can be net positive and you could
do that that you know that's
number one
uh you know as I carry that so that's
you know that's number one then I guess
it was the list that we went to you know
the second is you know what do you do
next
in terms of what do you need what do you
invest in you know and then and then you
know going Beyond it and then there
avoid the following mistake the most
common mistake of investing thinking
that the investment that did good
is a good investment
people rather more expensive
the things that quite often
those markets that did
really really well became more more
expensive and everybody smart money is
all the time compete comparing them and
competing
so what happens is
um the naive money
buys the thing that was hot or is hot
the thing that has been terrible which
might be the thing that's beaten down
so I would say also an important element
okay so here's another one that's really
important diversify
so don't put all your eggs in one basket
right because what I learned about this
is that first of all all Investments
uh compete and it's not easy to sell
tell whether one investment is better
than the other because if people could
do that life would be easy and everybody
make a ton of money
um so and this is a competitive game
that's very difficult to compete in so
it's very difficult to say which one's
better or worse you could take experts
and you could and do all sorts of tests
and you'll find out that they can pick
that and you can't tell whether the
worst ones are going to be better so
because of that you understand that um
even picking the best ones is difficult
and particularly if you're naive like we
spend hundreds of millions of dollars
each year on Research to try to give us
an edge okay now you've got to compete
with us so uh competing in the markets
is more difficult than competing in the
Olympics you wouldn't go think I'm going
to compete in the Olympics but there are
more people who try harder in order to
do that so it's a zero-sum game so but
diversification
um that they're different uh will reduce
your risk without
um reducing your return yeah so if you
know how to diversify well
so
um that's critical so I would say again
uh get get your savings right and the
reasons I say I would say
um have great humility about what you
what you don't know don't buy the thing
that was hot just because you think it's
hot
um and then know how to diversify well
that those would be the most important
things I could convey rule number eight
use the looping process know your goals
um know what you're going after
um you could have almost anything you
want but you can't have everything you
want and so you have to prioritize and
you move in that direction
on the way to your goals you're going to
encounter your problems and your
obstacles
so identifying now step two is
understanding your problems and your
obstacles identify them step three is to
diagnose them to get at the root cause
of the problem
and that could be many root causes but
it could also be your weaknesses or
weaknesses of others but you have to be
objective about them once you diagnose
them then you go to step four which is
to design a way to get around them
and then after you have that design you
implement that design so you have to
follow through and do it and you do that
and and that will then produce its new
results which should be better results I
have I call this kind of the looping
process it's the evolutionary looping
process and
um you do you just keep doing that and
you learn over a period of time and you
move in the direction that you want rule
number nine understand patterns there
were three things that happened in my
lifetime that are happening now that
didn't happen in my lifetime before and
that I needed to study and that was an
enormous amount of creation of debt and
the monetization of that in a financial
piece
the second is the internal conflict
populism of the right and the left
um that and with wealth gaps and so on
that I like to measure things that you'd
have to go back to 1900 to see those
degrees of conflict which I think are a
threat to our system and a democracy and
could produce a civil war type of
situation
and third the rise of a great power to
challenge an existing great power in the
existing World Order now those three
things in their degrees individually but
also collectively last time they
happened was 1930 to 45 period And so
when I what I needed to do was to
understand those patterns and those
things and I took it into it and so what
I'm hoping to show is simply the
mechanics of it in a lot of and then
explain why it appears that we are in an
important juncture now what we do with
that juncture so yes it's measured and
and there are the United States is in
relative to decline in my measures which
are measured and China has been rising
and that's an issue but that doesn't
create necessarily A Destiny it creates
a situation which I hope we can we'll go
through that and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is delay gratification I want to
distinguish there's big differences in
Opportunities yes so let's say supposing
you have two people of comparable
opportunities yes and then they were
going to do that okay
the marshmallow test yeah as you as you
know apparently is you take a kid and
you say okay uh you can have one
marshmallow now or you could have two
marshmallows in 15 minutes if you don't
eat the first one yeah if you don't eat
the first one right yep okay once you
start to realize
that deferred gratification
is going to make you better and so on
and you start to count count and you say
like something like how many
days weeks months or years can I live
if I don't have money come in and you
start to focus in on that
that's the first step okay like the
marshmallow test okay so I want to save
you got to start there then if you do
that
you're necessarily going to go save in
what
and then you'll start to get exposure
to
how these things are different
okay then you start to care I can have
one of these and one of those and you
start to experience
and then you start to learn
and basically that's what makes the
difference
my son in 2014 gave me a book by Joseph
Campbell called hero of a thousand faces
and basically he described that these
things happen you know everybody crashes
and then you're faced with uh that crash
and you either have an epiphany or you
don't now you either walk off the field
and say hey I don't want to do this
anymore and you give up on that going
after your audacious goals or you gain
really humility you you know how do you
feel that you're going to be wrong and
so I think then that whole notion is um
you know to come back with the
um finding the smartest people I could
find who disagree with me
um also I'm in the investment management
business that you have to bet against
the consensus
otherwise you can't make money because
it's in the price and you have to bet
against the consensus and be right or as
an entrepreneur I'm an entrepreneur I
had to bet against the consensus and be
right and so to gain that humility was
the the thing so you either get off the
field or you learn the average person
who's listening to many people think
that they can go into
this very difficult zero-sum game of
betting against the consensus and be
right
you know what I mean in other words
investors says I'm going to go in the
markets I'm going to make money betting
against the consensus and be right right
because the consensus is built into the
price okay okay that's what's up so it's
think of it as like going to a horse
race and there's handicaps okay you're
not going to pick the best horse and
you're not going to pick the best
company
a terrible company can be a better
investment than a a terrific company
a terrible company could be a better
investment just like the terrible horse
can be a better because the odds that
are changing like you go into that and
that becomes the long shot but because
the long shot is going to pay off 25 to
1.
right if he comes in
that you could just as likely bet on the
the long shot as the leader and it's
going to be equally likely that you're
going to make money right otherwise
you'd otherwise the market would be
doing the opposite well the market is
like that right in other words if
everybody believes that something's
going to be terrific okay then
everybody's betting on it and it's price
is high
so it's not what's best necessarily it's
what's best relative to what's in the
price what's discounted this has been
like the biggest message that I think
that I would get across that I'm trying
to convey in principles and so on
um is that
so many people in there have opinions in
their heads
that might be wrong and they're too
attached to them and if you know how to
operate with a certain amount of
uncertainty and stress test your
opinions in a different way use get away
from your ego get away from all that you
can learn a lot about raising your
probabilities and being right so what it
made me want to do is find the smartest
people I could find who disagreed with
me and then I could have conversations
with them you have to know what you're
going after
um you can't have everything in the
world but you could have
almost anything you want but you can't
have everything you want if you go after
your goals and they're clear you have to
know your goals the two big things is
how do you get your alignment of your
lower level you with your upper level
you how do you get um past your ego and
your blind spot and we know what the ego
barrier is like I got to be right or
whatever it is or I'm not good at this
the blind spot barrier is the
realization that people actually see
things different they see different
things like somebody will see the big
picture somebody will see the detail
they'll focus on different things almost
like a color spectrum type of thing and
if you realize that you will see a part
of that spectrum and other people will
see the other part of the spectrum and
so that you really need to when you go
above yourself you really need to
orchestrate all those ways of seeing
because you are not just one of those
people that's got to do it yourself your
way of being the the success is to go
above it and be the orchestrator and
know what you're good at and what you're
not good at so it's almost like if you
want your life to be successful you will
not let yourself do certain things
because you're just no good at them once
you get that picture down then you can
find the past wherever the paths are
you're open-minded because you now
you've given up your ego barrier and
your blind spot barrier I should explain
believability weighted decision making
to you if you sure if you're interested
okay so ordinarily you the two ways of
making decisions pretty much there's the
boss has control and autocratic
autocratic I'll call that autocratic
takes in everything and then he makes a
decision
or there's Democratic pretty much one
man one vote
but really the best decision making is
believability weighted decision making
and if you think about it first
conceptually
you would say if you're going to make a
decision of what you have medical
condition and you're going how are you
going to get that you're going to think
who are the best doctors Consulting
experts right consult the experts but
this one knows more and that one knows
less and how do you do it and then you
have this triangulation and then you
make that that's kind of the idea of
believability decision making we have
ways of signing believability that we
all agree are fair that we each assess
each other and we get certain amount of
believability points
so now imagine that you had
believability your believability on a
subject matter maybe it's investing
maybe it's accounting whatever the
subject is that you have a certain
amount of believability weighted points
and you're together well those
believability weighted points uh when
you say okay what should I make as a
decision now I'm responsible for
something but I ask everybody else I and
I take a believability way to vote I can
have a believability way to vote when I
have that believability way to vote vote
I really do believe that it's going to
be a better decision than I would
individually make that's believability
weighted decision making meditation is
the biggest gift that I can give anyone
and I would say more than anything it is
whatever reason for Success I've had
because it allows one
on back to the two U's I'll clarify what
I mean is that in your mind that we
think what do you want and the reality
is when you look at the neuroscience and
psychology that there are different
parts of your brain that want different
things
and so in the simplest sense there is
the logical part of the brain that
you're conscious of it's called the
conscious and you think you're being
logical and you want to make those
decisions
and then there's the subliminal below
the limbic system part of the brain
which is the emotional and it's not as
conscious to you but it has more of an
influence on you than really The Logical
one and so they're not aligned and so
when you're experiencing that pain or
let's say the ego right there were two
main things you got an ego barrier and a
blind spot barrier if you can get past
your ego barrier and you get past your
blind spot barrier you can accomplish
anything because you'll also know that
you don't have to do everything to you
don't have to figure it out yourself you
can take in from other people the
different ways to approach things in the
best possible way and so the realization
that we all are really struggling with
ourselves and to think which are which
is in control meditation helps to deal
with the alignment of those two things
you now you use a lot of computer
related algorithms to help you navigate
the market yeah you know algorithms are
what we call them today equations is
what we used to call them and so you
would write that down and what I learned
is by being clear then I could tell how
that decision would have worked in the
past in all different environments so it
gave me a lot of perspective on making
that decision I could test it through
the Great Depression and so on and then
I could find that if I use that same
algorithm I could take data from and
have the computer make decisions in
parallel with me and so and that is what
I recommend for everybody I recommend
they write down their principles and
then realize that almost any of those
principles can then be converted into
algorithms and so the computer was
making decisions in parallel with me
making decisions that part type of
partnership between me and the computer
and then also expressing the algorithms
was invaluable not only in the quality
of the decision making but also the qual
quality of the relationships that I had
with people I worked with knowing how to
adversify well is more important than
almost anything people don't understand
this is that an evergreen principle yes
that's an evergreen principle and the
reason I'm saying that the way it is
it's almost like a casino making it's
money okay okay the way that you do it
is you get an edge so now when you have
to make a bet I've got to bet against
the whole world the world has view on
something is reflected in the price
so when I think something is attractive
or unattractive that means I have to bet
against the whole world and whether
that's right or not that's difficult I
get it right you know more often than I
get it wrong but I'm going to get it
wrong sometimes and so when you can take
a lot of different bets what you can do
is like the casino you'll get your
average that your bet would be but
you'll reduce your risk of one of those
tables not being the table that's paying
off and so that margin that so I can
reduce my risk without reducing my
return by knowing how to diversify so 19
a
1979 80 81 I calculated that American
Banks had lent a lot more money to
emerging countries than those countries
are going to get paid back and I
anticipate that there would be a debt
crisis and with that an economic crisis
so that was my thinking
um and August 1982 Mexico defaulted on
its debt and a number of countries
followed and so because I said that I
got a lot of attention about that and I
thought that was going to be producing a
bear Market in stocks and I could not
have been more wrong August 1982 was the
exact bottom of the stock market and I
was wrong and as a result of that um
let's take my eight employees or I had
to let them go I lost money for myself I
lost money for and I had to borrow four
thousand dollars for my dad it was the
most painful one of the most painful
experiences but it was one of the best
experiences that ever happened to me in
my life because it it changed my
perspective about decision making it
made
um it may gave me the humility that I
needed and fear of being wrong in my
decisions while I was able to maintain
my aggressiveness so it changed my whole
approach to decision making
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if the person's
doing the vision board and they're
saying when I get my new car I get my
new house I get my new relationship then
I'm gonna feel so great now that well
then they're back to the program